well first of all congratulations on
this beautiful film and it's standing
ovation
yeah how about that
that means that
they liked it which is wonderful yeah
well it's it's such a beautiful way to
showcase your career your milestones
what did it feel like watching it all
back
it was um
i learned a couple of lessons myself
yeah yeah remembering
a lot of things that i was a part of
it was like yeah i remember that you
know
really nice memories yeah and then to
see
the accomplishments that they made
there's
there's a great deal of the movie that
is about your contributions and you
being the artists that bridge the gap
when you look at artists now and how
how they're seen around the globe do you
see your influence in terms of people
being represented people of different
colors being represented
um
not as much as i'd like to
and i still think that um
diversity still has a lot
to go yes um it's it's being done which
is a good thing but i think it can be
amped up a bit
and hopefully you know it will be
yeah
there must have been
over the course of your career
many opportunities like this that have
come your way a lot of times people say
let's tell your life story let's her
life story why was it now and this
particular project which was the right
one well it's time people have been
coming to me asking me to do something
of this nature i hadn't lived long
enough
to kind
so you know i think the time is right
now i think i've
i've lived
quite a few years now and
i feel done some
very decent things you know and uh
um
[Music]
time to let everybody else know that
this is the real story it's not what has
been
fabricated open
thought that it should be
this is the way it really is
yeah letting everybody see
the real me yeah absolutely
one of the things that we love about the
bill you is just your bravery and it
it's apparent from in very early on in
the movie where it's showing how you
were early on in your career
where did that bravery come from that
that you know you just saying i'm going
to do me you know don't tell me tell me
what to do yeah exactly i know it and
that's the way i was brought up
you know people
can't be anyone other than who you are
and i don't want to be anybody else i
like me yeah you know
um
i think that the choices you make
the ones you have to live with
and
i'm pretty succinct about the choices i
had wonderful parents
my family itself
still is those who are still with us
um
completely um
i wouldn't trade them for the world you
know you know i'm happy i was born into
this particular family
[Music]
we care about each other we encourage
each other
we definitely love each other
so um
that's the way i was brought up
yeah you know do what you have to do
make sure it's done
with the kind of passion that that it
takes to accomplish yes
and that that love and admiration
certainly extends to your friends and
your peers as well you know
i feel very very fortunate you know
there are too many people that can truly
say that's my friend
and i
has been
shown
those that i call fred
but they are my friends no
those are the moments where
if they needed me i was there and if i
needed them they were there
regardless what the situation happened
to me
and that's um
showing how much you really care
there's a really lovely moment
a part that i just thought was
hysterical when you're talking about
um if you want to hit
um look at the ones i said no to and
that's what's going to be a hit
i think that's true it's a fun idea for
an artist that wants to be in charge to
kind of
realize
i don't know everything
exactly
let me tell let me let me fix it
you're right
speaking of um you know your your peers
that you've worked with your friends
that we were talking about what does it
feel like to have to see on screen
your friends like elton john people like
alicia keys um talking about how much
of an influence you've been on them yeah
that was
pretty enlightening you know
um
[Music]
i'm happy that um
that they've been watching me as i've
been watching them you know and if
whatever it is that i do or how i do it
makes a difference in how they approach
things
i'm thrilled to have been able to
give that
you know
it's the same as i feel i've been able
to
reap the benefits of what i got from
ella fitzgerald from lena horne and
sammy davis jr you know
merely saying okay that's how you do it
okay got it
so if i have been that influential on
any of them
you know that that makes you feel great
that sammy davis junior roast is
timeless
it's i loved it
and but it shows also just
just how funny you are if anyone is
following you on twitter because you're
reading supreme on twitter right now
they're seeing that as well
yeah i'm curious about you know you've
had all these different phases of your
career and you've you know you fought
against things and you've gone with the
flow in other cases
and now you're reaching out to this
other generation of people on twitter
yeah who are appreciating your sense of
humor your personality um
as well as your music what's it like to
reach out to an entirely new generation
it's wonderful you know what i'm
truly thrilled about
is how they're accepting your honesty
and how i am approaching them with that
and letting them know that's the way it
has to be done with them as well you
know everything
and i i usually tell them i said
everything's done with a smile
you know a smile
you don't get wrinkles from smiling all
right and i refuse that freak
you know so
i think the the tone of twitter has
changed since i've been on it because
i'm thrilled to be able to stay and jack
has even said to me he says where have
you been where have you been we're so
happy to be with us but i think it's the
presence of a true grown-up on twitter
that the kids that i've been interfacing
with and answering questions or asking
questions
they feel obliged to
respect and this thing is showing
i think most people are saying that's
what it has changed to tell nothing you
know there's not as much bashing or
cursing or any of those ugly things that
were going on
you know
and uh you know they know
[Music]
mtd ain't gonna play
they're gonna take you the chance okay
[Laughter]
well also some wonderful collaborations
can come out of twitter yes and it's
what's been happening you've you've got
um something coming up with chance
rapper which i'm very yes we recorded
a duet and
it's lovely
um it probably won't be out until the
first of the year
um getting it ready now and um i'll be
working with the beginner as well
i'm going to approach taylor swift the
people i've been in touch with here who
are also in the industry
i will be speaking to them to see you
know
how they feel about going to the city
everything that's awesome yeah
i mean
everyone's going to say yes not
necessarily
not necessarily
the other one that i think is very
exciting it's very cool is the
connection you made with china taylor
yes and now you're going to be working
on this on your story together yes it's
going to be based
we're taking my music
and creating
vignettes based on the songs i've signed
nice and uh
this is she's
she's brilliant
i love her a lot you know she's
funny as all get out she is
hey yeah that's what i love about it i
mean she's so much
like me
but sometimes it's scary
but she's brilliant and um
i think it's going to be something that
most people want to see
and it's very exciting well
congratulations again on everything i
hope you enjoy your time here oh yeah i
always love to i'm watching how toronto
has grown my goodness i've been coming
here doing concerts sincerely six months
so i know this is toronto very well
but it's been wonderful it really is
well we're excited thrilled that you're
here thank you so much
you